with what's going on in our society with
women and the autonomy of their bodies
it's important that art reflects life
it's an honor to get to explore this
story because I know hard conversations
have to be had surrounding missing women
and human trafficking
you don't hear about it you don't read
about it the rape murder and trafficking
of black and brown girls has never been
anyone's priority ever in any capacity
Gabrielle she is an advocate for
survivors of sexual trauma she's very
outspoken about her own past with sexual
trauma and I think she really relied on
the strength and the pain that she's had
to Grapple with
my story is pretty well known I've been
talking about for the last 25 years I
was raped and beaten at 19 in the Bay
Area a lot of the locations are very
familiar a lot of the situations are
very familiar I've had 30 years to
intimately understand sexual violence
against black and brown girls and how we
are systemically ignored and blamed for
our own trauma she brought a grit and a
fire she's brilliant but I know it also
cost her you are doing a lot of good in
this world so I want to do more
[Music]
I need to do more the thing about trauma
is it's not linear and surviving and
healing is not linear we really pull
back the curtain on how a girl becomes
groomed how she's trafficked and the
aftermath the attempts to reclaim your
life
season three is so full of deep
heartbreak courage and also Triumph of
the human spirit
it's looking at the juxtaposition
between the way the police the media and
the government respond to young white
women and the way they respond to
minority groups the fact that they are
being left behind it's really tied to
something happening in Oakland happening
in our country and in our world where we
could highlight an issue that people
were not talking about that they really
should be we need you to put
a department to bring these girls home
their real circumstances that people are
living every day and if we can shine a
light on this subject maybe we can save
a life it's taken me 30 years to unpack
and through this show and hopefully
through me and my history we can give it
the large platform and the attention it
deserves it feels like we are fighting
for our very breath our very life
because there's legit women and girls
and boys hanging in the balance
it's that important the work that we're
doing season three is that important and
everyone understood the assignment
my name is Poppy Scoville and I need you
to reconsider you have no idea what that
little thing can mean to a survivor
[Music]
[Applause]